l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj prima di cominciare la
puntata di unboxing di oggi volevo
soltanto dirvi che questa è l'ultima
puntata di unboxing da aprile partirà la
nuova serie che si chiama esperimento
incredibile nel frattempo vi lascio al
video con un ospite d'eccellenza e
niente buona visione ragazzi salve
youtubers noi facciamo un'altra i
ragazzi che vivete questo nuovi dio sono
stati j
e oggi siamo in un nuovo episodio di
unboxing come sempre non è vero non è
sempre così però ogni tanto ogni tanto
ci sono degli ospiti un po particolari e
speciali che riporto su questa serie
incredibile di volta c'è stata noemi
oggi ci sarà da pericolosissime si capì
così alto rischio la vita li mai
divenuto il lavoro dello youtuber non è
pericoloso dello però predetti che ha
detto salve ragazzi allora karim si è
prestato a questa cosa incredibile
sorgenti che aspettavi solo questo dato
è aperto sia na li voglio fini in un box
bene non so io non so cosa c'è dentro
non penso neanche tu da me lorenzo lavia
l'euro sono con te lo dico perfetto e
che lo sappiamo sono sempre l'ultimo a
sapere le cose quindi pescato diamo il
pacco di oggi vediamo cosa riusciamo a
darci un taglio va bene e per di scatola
ma ci serve l'attrezzo del mestiere io
mi fai da parte di questo namenti
trebbia no ti prego la mera così
perfetto voi faccio lo faccio io faccio
è fatto scudetto apri tutto io
bravissimo guarda che non sono gravi io
faccio solo questa la mattina alla sera
ma non sono aperte perché si è gettato
anche ok ci siamo io spero di non
trovare gain terapico ha dentro come ti
ho già detto riparte benissimo si parte
benissimo la facciamo vedere
innanzitutto dal primo che dobbiamo
partire o forzata questo e allora io
sono felice come un bambino di fare
questa cosa ha bisogno a montarlo pc che
riusciamo a farlo in due quindi se è mai
occupata di problema dall'altra parte
ora io mi sento 123 qui perché non
ridere che caldo da fare anche abbiamo
penalizzato qua la perfetta per questo
episodio dove facciamo vedere perché
signorile siamo e nient'altro
nella chiusura dell'unica bambini
abbiamo fatto il primo accordo ce ne
sono 2 mila andiamo col prossimo
allora io non capisco io non sto capendo
navigato perché la motivazione ma va
bene così si sta guardandosi c'è di
peggio doce 316 sì c'è qualcosa liner a
questo no tengo io se permessi arcieri
esplicitiamo ovviamente rivolto invece
che ci sia scritto articoli religiosi
sullo stato del papa
meno male che si può confondere election
nota black shaun film bellissimo che mi
hanno fatto identico mentre altri che
sono più di bambini sono completamente
diverse
non capisco il motivo del perché c'è qua
dentro questo fatto però si trova si
trova benissimo grazie si assicuri
nell'angolo lisce e ne dice il video
venedì hanno preferito next ha saputo
prendere questo allora abbiamo chi sia
questo questa è roma races che non ha
idea di chi sia però spiego io è un
lottatore attuale armi e viene odiato da
tutti perché la dublin l'ha fatto
vincere ma nessuno lo voleva l'hanno
obbligato a farlo vincere a far piacere
alla gente ma la gente la janara e non
ci assomiglia niente queste reti
nell'arco delle vetture completamente
stop è arrivato francesco era uguale che
bello
esattamente quello che volevo da bambino
sta infilando spaventosamente ho paura
era un certo punto a parte ci ammazzi
tutti però però vabbè e niente quindi di
scatto diamo il nostro come credito
roman rhames che nessuno vuole e vabbè
ma non ce n'era una che combatte da solo
però abbiamo acceso salta il ciocco
francese vuole per il piano solare
la manata che li sta per arrivare e
incredibile come la prova ad avvicinare
non penso di aver mai visto un ring
migliore di questo però dunque giocatori
puoi fare quello che vuoi assolutamente
dagli fantasia
speriamo di non offende nessuno prima
nave spear a papà francese lo fai
partire dalla terza corda l'ho lo
colpisci però poi card ipotizzo
non so perché non riesce a prenderlo
incontro polare devo provare a vedere se
riuscivo a fare la dbs tradire in di
orto ma non vedo non c'è il gancio
peccato pare dalla terza corda
addirittura ammazzo proprio sul pubblico
e listino va bene ringraziamo e lui e
farla francesco per incredibile
performance sul ring e passiamo al
prossimo livello di e non avevo visto ma
avevamo anche adam undertaker e io
strauss lo sapevo prima riscatto chiamo
l'ho mi manca il camper purtroppo colore
non ce l'abbiamo il camper una delle pop
quella massa critica ciò vedere poi c'è
la porticina e tendente rometti
l'incenso lo bruci fuori allora abbiamo
heisenberg col cappello addirittura casa
la puntata nelle proporzioni software
economia cucina cos'è un love affair
borgo bellissimo niente con tanto di
cappello dire che non ho mai fatto da di
via vaglio benissimo e dopo di che
c'abbiamo versione mlg ecco la lai non
ci sarà solo più non si sarebbero più
nei pac di mld cia c'è anche lui
io direi di metterlo sull'over board e
rilasciarlo vicino a papà francesco in
questo momento va da solo viola si dai
finalmente una roba che conosco anche io
per questo il nostro ciclica pense c'è
il flusso canalizzatore però non c'è
quindi questo mi multa tale prezzo di
pietro si apre la portiera
c'è un flusso canalizzatore mai
bruttissimo perché il grigio non è
neanche colorato però c'è una volta
inserito il cavo bisogna raggiungere la
velocità di tempo e poi questo si
aggancia mi piace come glissato sulla
velocità perché non tra ricordare ad
hunter era quello sta bene e questo si
aggancia qualsiasi cosa qui immagino
questo ladra ring perché modo di
intersecare le varie cose che troviamo
non so come un fulmine possa colpire un
ring siamo farlo all'aperto non solo
parla perche sa mai
vabbè andiamo sugli ultimi due e
scegliere questo scegliere 03 sono tre
scusami hanno visto una gattara santo
iddio scusa poi promozione sulla faccia
della signora espone anche perché è poi
c'è il giappone capello ma perché io non
capisco la motivazione o meglio di tutto
prima magari una bimba una bimba mentre
principessa astronauta una gattara ma
poi non è per sempre soci qualcosa una
gatta la più generica e sabrina quindi
sabrina e di scrittura che si vendono va
a fare anche le action figures non l'ha
proprio questa secondo me è ottimo per
il ring è ottima per il ricordato i
personaggi da ritirata tutto gira
intorno al risotto se gli sta sulla
spalla la gattare ancora quella di voi
nell'oratorio ci starà mai però hai una
mossa di breslin incredibile è un
capolavoro un capolavoro e mancano
2 11
abbiamo il nostro prossimo wrestler semi
sempre più snodati manca l'ultima cosa
che è questa che alien
credo che sia il soldato il set per il
combattimento con il combattimento poi
allenato andati male non l'abbiamo preso
so bene cosa farci su un idea non so
neanch'io però che questo sono che non
vale nelle regole di combattimento
l'arbitro non vede ragazzi questa cosa
non credo sia necessario dalle varie
tutto però almeno uno di questi
io lo metterei o non sta malissimo da un
mezzo al casinò arrivate ciao ragazzi
basta
penso che non ci sia un rischio salame
mixato in crisi nei dodici anni di gara
sopra vedere i memi di facebook di tu
col tamburo chiusi e qualcosa sullo
soldi è stato piacere suonare con lei e
per questo è stato l'unboxing con il
signor karim ragazzi quindi ragazzi
questo era tutto quello che potevo
mostrarvi oggi di qualità però vi sia
piaciuto
ringrazio signor karim per averci fatto
a questa scultura sono molto felice del
risultato le dico anch'io quindi spero
che vi sia piaciuto come se vicino al
momento mi piace passato anche dal
canale di carini che fa le interviste da
oggi non più però la sala carlo v nata
tutta la carriera e se non siete ancora
chi ti scrive qua volano gli oggetti che
pericolosissimo ma mi sa che non ci
vediamo come sempre ciao
[Musica]
si celebra oggi
il matrimonio tra roman reigns e iceberg
siamo qui miti per celebrare il sail
sacro vincolo del matrimonio è un
bologna e il bologna poi tu heisenberg
perché non vi ricordo sono come prendere
in sposa inserire nome qui in rosa con
il matrimonio vuoi tu roma reims
prendere in sposo è qui presente
heisenberg in salute in malattia in
droghe yes può baciare lo sposo no io
sono o no hai una figlia da quando da
quando gli subita ridiventata crimini
giur
air berlin non possiamo convalidare il
matrimonio ha una figlia
come no ma già che ci sono o no è morto
amen iscrive iscrivete lasciate un like
e ci teniamo ad un prossimo ci vediamo
al prossimo video
sarebbe stupido
[Musica]